here with reaction fox news contributor
ari fleischer and the founder of the
committee to unleash prosperity steve
moore steve 17 billion in new taxes uh
for people making under 200 000 a year
uh the people that said don't raise
taxes during a recession that would have
been mansion obama and pelosi we have
them on tape we've played it before
a lot of pork in this bill
a lot of it related to the green new
deal and we're nearly up to 4 trillion
in new debt
uh under biden in only 18 months that's
got to be a new record
yeah it is sean and you did a great job
of summarizing this bill i just want to
amplify one thing that you said which is
the state that is the biggest loser here
from this massive green energy agenda is
clearly west virginia i do not
understand why joe manchin sold out his
own state he thinks somehow this is
going to lead to more coal and oil and
gas production are you kidding me with
the with the
epa and the interior department of joe
biden who wants to kill those industries
that ain't going to happen and so you're
looking at
this is the fourth major bill as you
just said that massively increases the
amount of green energy funding i i
calculate almost a half a trillion
dollars into this green energy for uh
electric vehicles for windmills for
solar panels you know sean we get about
six or seven percent of our energy from
wind and solar power it's completely
insignificant and this will hurt our oil
and gas industry it's going to give all
this money to the climate change
industrial complex and one other thing
you left out sean don't forget the the
bit the other big pay for in this bill
is these price controls on the uh on the
drug industry how are we going to have
things like operation war speed how are
we going to win the race for the cure
for alzheimer's and parkinson's and
cancer and als and and lou gehrig's
disease if we're if we're taking money
out of an industry that saves lives i
don't get it you know ari from a
political point of view newt gingrich
had a good point he's challenging every
republican running in every office for
the house or senate to go back and
challenge their opponents to debate just
on this bill alone uh i think that would
be a good opportunity to get this out
before people especially during the
august recess
but that's also going to mean that that
republican senators will will have to
use parliamentary maneuvers to keep this
thing
afloat
through the vacation i hope they do that
yeah i don't see how this is a political
winner for the democrats unless they're
counting on the left-wing base of the
democrat party that just thinks the
world's going to end in 12 years or now
i guess we're down to ten or eight uh
for them to no longer sit on their hands
and get out to vote because of all the
hundreds of billions of subsidies that
are going to causes that i suppose they
support but the bigger damage too is
this bill really should be named the
raise taxes and push the economy deeper
into recession act
i have never in my entire career heard
of somebody who thinks it's good public
policy to raise taxes here as the nation
is entering a recession
that prolongs recessions that doesn't
stimulate the economy that doesn't give
you the help that you need it makes
things worse and why
for really what's essentially corporate
welfare this is a gigantic spending bill
to give money to green corporate welfare
and that's what so much of the green
industry has grown up into without
subsidies they would never be
competitive would never exist and the
more subsidies you give them the more
they're just hooked on government
and that's what this bill does and joe
manchin a moderate no he's a a mini
green new dealer
is there any chance
exit question for both the any chance
chance steve moore that um
kristen cinema says no i don't believe
it's possible she
look i think she could be wonder woman
here i think she can save our country
i'm i'm praying that she stops this
horrible bill she would be a hero
uh sean in the state of arizona if she
just said no to this bill it's bad for
arizona by the way arizona it kills
manufacturing and arizona is a major
manufacturing state so let's let's uh
hope that kirsten sermon it's amazing by
the way there's 250 democrats in
congress and only one of them is opposed
to this horrible bill
yeah ari what do you think does kristen
cinema go along with the 49 colleagues
or stand up for the people arizona
nobody knows i think her silence right
now is telling that would make me think
that she's leaning on the no side
but the the mirror image of john mccain
the senator from arizona who famously
put his thumb down
to kill the repeal of obamacare and vote
with the democrats was a hero for doing
it and kristen cinema who now represents
arizona having the chance to come in and
do the same thing
on this recession-causing green new deal
corporate subsidy bill uh the parallel
is ironic
i'll believe it if i see it i'll i'll
put it that way count me as a skeptic
all right ari thank you steve thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else